I was reading the New York Times Book
Review one Sunday and there was a review
of a new translation of the Aeneid
Virgil epic about a man whose mission is
to found Rome he leaves troy which is a
disaster
you know this whole city is destroyed
and then he finds founds Rome which is
going to be an empire and destroy a lot
more cities so that's an interesting
like why would you leave troy and found
Rome that's always an interesting
question in the middle he goes to
Carthage and he falls in love with a
woman who is a queen and who's building
a new city and there is this idea of Oh
a different city that's not involved in
war and destruction and empire that's
involved in the arts and commerce and a
man and woman would ruin rule as equals
but no no no no he has to leave her to
fulfill his mission that's the old old
old epic from so long ago it should be
out of date but it's of course not
anyway I was reading this book review
which was praising this new translation
by Fitzgerald it is exquisite and it's
zeroed in on the place where Annie's
goes to the underworld to look for his
father and he needs Dido who he's
startled to see to realize that after he
abruptly left her to fulfill his mission
she had killed herself and he says to
her I couldn't believe I would hurt you
so terribly by going I remember sitting
it was Sunday morning and I thought how
could a sensitive intelligent man not
know the effects of his action on
someone who he really loved you know he
was deeply involved with I never thought
how crazy for a woman in that situation
where you feel somebody's deeply
connected with you and loves you and art
as if there was no connection and I
thought Virgil was however many hundred
years ago I thought but this is very
contemporary this story goes on and on
so out of that came the characters Keira
and undress she's an architect building
a city he's carrying the household gods
he's carrying from Europe of the 20th
century and he's directing opera
he's a musician and a theatre director
so they meet and they each had huge
losses that are part of that history of
that's still going on if people who you
know whose lives have been shattered by
political conflict in war it goes on all
the time so they're not planning to fall
in love and the two of them fall in love
with each other because you can just see
these two are going to be obviously
attracted to each other
so that's how the novel starts and then
because I'm writing in about a
contemporary woman I mean she doesn't
commit suicide like Virgil's Dido
but what happens when he leaves her is
she does feel what's happened to her
sense of reality so she goes into she's
a modern woman she goes into therapy so
the whole second part of the novel there
are new characters Greta the therapist
comes in and Roya her friend who's an
architect anyway I was not planning to
write a novel and out of that came this
novel Keira which was amazing to write
because it took me into just incredible
worlds including the world of
architecture